Hey, Charlene
Yeah, Jake?
You, uh, wanna...
go to prom with me?
I thought you'd never ask!
I would love to
Oh, man
I don't know why I was just so nervous
Hey, Jake?
Yeah, Charlene?
Did you know that only like
2% of high school sweethearts wind up married?
And more than half of them end up divorced?
Yeah, I mean, when you think about it
with 7.4 billion people on Earth, the odds that we'd find
our soulmates in this small town of 1,379 people is mathematically impossible
So we agree!?
I mean, we're good with this for the time being
but it's not gonna be, like, a long-term thing?
Oh, of course not
I'd never want to be in a relationship when I go off to college
I love that about you
And I love you
Until orientation week
and then, we will never talk again
Oh, yeah, obviously
(ANNOUNCER 1)
27 minutes and 35 seconds until the big game!
But who's countin'?
(ANNOUNCER 2)
I'm countin'!
27 minutes and 29 seconds
(ANNOUNCER 2)
28 seconds!
27 seconds!
(ANNOUNCER 2)
26 seconds!
25 seconds!
Huddle up, huddle up, huddle up!
Alright boys listen up
Big game tonight
Yeah
A wise man once said to me
Life is a game
of inches
And every inch we need, is around us
We tear ourselves to pieces for that inch!
We claw with our fingernails
for that inch!
Isn't that the Any Given Sunday speech?
Yes
What do I have to do to reach you guys?!
If you lose
you're gonna be known as losers, now and forever
You wanna be known as losers for the rest of your lives?
Huh?
Huh!?
We're not losers, Coach.
What's that?
We love football, but, but you're ruining it.
Most of us won't ever play again at the end of this season
But we will go on to be doctors
and lawyers
and teachers!
Football's just a game
But life
Yeah, life
is what we choose to make of it!
Jake Ramsey
You are by far
the stupidest kid I ever met in my entire life!
I'm done, Coach
What does that mean?
I'm not playing tonight
Me too!
Yeah I'm out...I'm out too...Me too!...I'm out!
Hey, don't ruin this for me
If we win tonight
I've got a job waiting for me
at Texas City Junior College
Wait
They have a football team?
Uh huh!
And I'll be the special assistant of the special teams coach
If I win tonight
If we win tonight
Well, then come on boys
Let's go get ourselves a win
and never see Coach again!
NO MORE COACH!